now we've got everything we need to play
basic sound effects with no on-the-fly
audio processing the only thing we have
left to do is to adjust the volume of
various effects based on where to happen
in the game world for example when my
character picks up quad damage I hear
that full volume an explosion that
happens in the distance may only be
heard at half volume and it won't even
hear an enemy who picks up an energy
canister on the far edges of the map now
grits uses a pretty simple distance
calculation based on the view rekt size
we want to be able to hear the sounds
within the screen radius at full volume
then we'll want to scale down the volume
to 0 as we reach 2 times the radius
finally you won't hear any sound at all
outside of that radius